Let's look at the solution to
our second Write-Update versus
Write-Invalidate quiz.
This time we have a program where
one core repeatedly reads and
then writes A and then the other.
So how many bus uses do we
get with the write update and
the write-invalidate protocol?
This time,
the write update protocol is going to
have one bus access here to read,
because this is a miss.
Because there is no sharing,
the write doesn't need a write access.
because we know that we privately
have this thing in our cache.
So, this is what happens the first time.
In the remaining 499 iterations of this,
nothing else happens.
We just hit in our cache.
Once we get to core one however, the
reading is going to get the data from
core zero but now we have the shared
bits at one and both caches.
So the write here will need to
do a broadcast the first time.
And then the next time and so on.
So overall we get 1 for
the initial miss.
And then 500 updates of core 0's cache.
Note that this is wasteful because
core 0 is no longer really interested
in this.
So overall we get 502 bus accesss.
In a right invalidate protocol,
we have the same thing here.
We have a miss and
the data is not shared, so
the right and all of the reason right
after that are just cache hits.
However here what happens is the read
here will make the data shared and
fetch the data from the other core.
So that's going to be a miss.
Because the data is shared,
the right will have to do
an invalidation broadcast.
So we will have another bus access, but
that makes the data private to core one
now because this version is invalidated.
So for the remaining 499 iterations
of this, nothing else happens.
So overall we get only
three bus accesses.
As you can see, write-in validate is
a lot more efficient if data tends to
be used frequently on one core and then
the frequent use moves to another core.